Okay,
good morning.
You are the last people left standing,
right.
I can tell you to beginning
of the semester which of
these lectures we'll have
the lowest attendance rate and it's this
one and I'll tell you where it's going
to peak again as we get closer to the
final exam. But you were the good folks.
You're, you're here, you're
sticking with it. So good for you.
If you can make it the section on
tonight and tomorrow, that's great too.
What are we doing today?
Well,
last time we left off talking about
opera in the 19th century and the session
before that we were talking about the
development of the piano in the 19th
century. Today, what do we want to do?
We're going to talk about the
development of the symphony,
specifically the symphony orchestra in
the course of the 19th century and it did
undergo significant
changes as we will see. Uh,
what symphonies have we
visited here in our course?
Who can give me the name of the
symphony that we have studied?
Roger Beethoven's Fifth Symphony.
We did a lot with at the very beginning
of the class. And he any other symphony?
Elizabeth Beethoven's six,
which was the basis of the Saybrook
concert. Any other symphonies? Uh,
Angela Beethoven's night. Yes, we
talked about that in an earlier lecture.
Yadadadada odd, odd. Edd, Edd, EDD
dating. So we've done a lot of Beethoven.
Uh, we haven't [inaudible]
the surprise of good,
the surprise symphony of Joseph
Hide. So we've done some Haydn, uh,
anything else we haven't mentioned?
Somebody I thought you might mention.
Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee Dee
Mozart. Okay. Mozart d minor symphony.
So we've done Mozart, Haydn,
and Beethoven for the most part,
but there's a lot of symphonic composition
after these individuals extends into
the early 20th century. And that's
what we're going to track today.
So today's lecture will generally be
about the symphony from one animal to the
other.
M you hear about the three B's and music.
While these are the two m's
from Mozart to, uh, Gustaf.
Moller let's start with Mozart.
Let's play just a little
bit of his decline and knock
music a little night music.
It's a, it's a sort of, uh, divertimento
evening music for entertainment.
Let's listen to a little bit about
it and then I'll say something
[inaudible].
Let's stop there. What can we
say about that music? Well,
we've talked a lot about this before.
It's very pattern. It's very symmetrical.
It's balanced.
We have antecedent,
consequent and they come into
music with the classical period.
What about the orchestra?
Well,
it's rather small in that it's
dominated principally by the strings.
And we had a couple of listening exercises
where we'd see the strings play the
themes and then the woodwinds maybe come
back to echo them or to answer them.
But most of the musical material is
getting presented by the, by the strings.
Um,
the texture,
well the texture is rather thin here
because it's not a very big orchestra,
a thin texture. And what can we
say also about the texture? Well,
it tends to be rather polyphonic
I'm a phonic or monophonic well,
in that case homophonic
homophonic basically you've
got a melody plus a company.
Um,
and we could also say something.
We've talked about that this music has
a kind of rhetorical strategy to it.
We have this idea of music.
It sounds like a melody,
sounds like a theme or music that sounds
like it's coming between teams that
leading a similar transitional music, um,
music that may be a contrasting theme.
Usually that ends a section.
So it's music that does something,
music that's trying to get us from point
a to point B and point c and so on.
So it's a sort of rhetorical music,
teleological music,
if you will. Uh, okay,
now let's turn to a
piece of romantic music.
And before we do that, I'm going
to say a thing or two about this,
a romantic music. It's a piece, uh,
by Tchaikovsky from his Romeo and Juliet.
And I think we have the titles
of the pieces that will be, uh,
listening to on the board up there today.
So from his Romeo and Juliet,
and you've probably heard this music
before because it used to be a lot of it
used to be used in cartoon music.
You know,
anytime there's a love seeing this
particular music would, would come on.
So what are its qualities
here? Uh, well, first of all,
it has a long sweeping that
melody here in romantic music,
long sweeping melody that is
rather a symmetrical in shape.
Instead of having neat units
of two plus two plus two,
it could go on over bars or maybe
it'll be a seven bar phrase,
something like that.
So the melodies tend to be long.
They tend to be asymmetrical rhythm.
Think about rhythm in the music
that we've been listening to.
My paradigm here is the beginning
of the Brandenburg fifth, uh, uh,
con Concerto Grosso in which the
rhythm starts out [inaudible] it's very
regular.
It's like a machine gun almost or a
sewing machine or some kind of repetitive
process there.
When we get into the classical period,
rhythm is somewhat more relaxed,
but it is still a pattern Dum
de team that Dah, Dah, Dah,
um, bom, bom, Bom, bom.
But here with this
music in the romantic period, the themes
are not only long and asymmetrical,
the rhythms don't seem to shake out in
patterns that allow us to tap our feet or
allow us to conduct it easily.
So we have ties over bars.
We have lots of syncopation. We have
irregular phrasing, somewhat irregular,
a metrical patterns as well.
Tempo.
We've talked a little bit about this
before and this idea of tempo robot hoe
here in romantic music,
we get wild swings of tempo in that they
can be coming along at a regular pace
and then slow way,
way down,
and then speed up to get back on
track and slow down and so on.
And this is part in parcel parcel of the
romantic aesthetic in the sense that it
tends to swing wildly from one extreme
to another wildly in terms of rhythm and
wildly in terms of dynamics. We can
go from very, very quiet to very,
very loud in a way that
Mozart couldn't remember.
We were talking about Mozart's piano,
which weighed about one 10th of
what this piano ways up here.
This piano probably
weighs about 800 pounds.
Mozart's probably weighed
about a hundred pounds,
so this is much bigger instrument.
You can play very quietly on it
or you can make a huge sound.
And same thing with the orchestra and
we'll come back to that point today.
Mozart header,
a modest orchestra Mauler at the end
of this period at a huge orchestra.
So this allows for these wild swings.
The romantic period is
sort of a bipolar period,
I guess in turn in terms of music in
that regard. Okay. Having said that,
let's listen to what we might call a
prototypical moment in romantic music.
Out of checkoff skis,
overture to Romeo and Juliet.
Now it starts to build a little
bit of melodic sequence working on
reaching higher and higher
and we'll phase it out there.
So some really remarkable it's made
possible by this newly enlarged orchestra.
So let's talk about this orchestra for
a moment and we're going to reference
here our four food types or are
for instrumental groups for uh,
the, uh, for classical art
music, starting with the strings,
we don't really have any new
instruments here in the romantic period.
We still have basically the four
string instruments of violin, viola,
cello and double bass.
But they are different.
They're different from the or from the
instrument that Mozart was playing.
What happened? Well, in the 19th century,
the construction of the violin
was changed rather significantly.
And I think I could just sort
of hold my hand out here,
maybe demonstrate this kind of thing.
First of all,
there was a higher bridge put on it.
If you have the bridge holding up the
strings in a an 18th century violin,
it might be like that
19th century violent,
like that higher bridge that
allows you to have more tension.
It puts more tension on,
on the entire instrument.
And at the same time,
the strings that had been used,
which were made of anybody have a sense
of what violin strings in the 18th
century were made up.
Um,
Chelsea cat gut sometimes.
Yes, yes. Animal lovers,
cat gut more normally sheep
guts. Okay. So she got, um,
uh,
and uh,
they that wouldn't sustain the attention
that could be put on that was not as
great as if you were using a wire string.
So in the 19th century to
technological advances wire, strange,
more tension, higher
bridge, uh, and to co,
well also the fingerboard was extended.
It's longer.
So oftentimes the strata of areas, they
chop off the fingerboard and put another,
a new finger board on it and put
it all back together again. Um,
what else?
Uh,
I know I'm missing one other
important thing. March.
Well maybe that will have to do,
do it for the moment. And what would we
end up? Oh, I know it was a boat. The bow,
the bow.
If you look at an 18th century bone,
go to our collection of historical
musical instruments on Hillhouse Avenue.
The amount of horse hair
there is rather narrow.
It's almost double when you get to the
19th century boats. So the bow is bigger.
So the whole thing is more powerful.
And I've asked Jacob just
to bring in his a viola,
which is fundamentally a 19th
century viola in construction.
And just rip through a couple of things
just to give you a sense of the volume
of the instrument
playing it.
Okay.
So that's all I wanted him to do.
But just to give you a sense that's
a big rich south play. A couple of,
can you play a couple of chords,
may,
maybe the ending of something with
double and triple stop. Too much volume.
Okay,
so big powerful 19th century violin as
opposed to the smaller one that Ma the
Mozart had. Let's talk about the
woodwinds here. In this family.
New instruments were introduced. First of
all, we have the Piccolo up at the top.
We've heard the Piccolo before.
Remember in the storm scene of the
pastoral symphony number six of Beethoven
storm scene,
if you wanted to get a sense of the
whistling wind up there and that's what he
did, he had to pick a low point, way
away a pie and you could hear it.
There's kind of gave that effect.
Uh, at the other end of the extreme,
we have the double, uh, the contract
or double bassoon being added,
the low bassoon playing down an
octave lower than a, is that correct,
Linda planed down an octave
or even lower than that.
Okay.
It's enormous.
And actually I think the bassoon,
the contra pursuant plays lower than
any instrument in the orchestra.
Is that correct?
In terms of actual frequency.
So it's adding to the both the
high and the low range of the,
of the woodwind family.
And a new instrument was introduced
actually it had been around in certain
quarters,
a new instrument called the English horn.
And I think we have that up
there on our list of terms. Uh,
is the English horn from
England and is it a horn? No,
it's actually from France and Germany.
And it's a woodwind instrument.
It's not a brass instrument at all.
It's kind of a low or tenor oboe.
So it's a kind of oboe in a tenor range,
but it has a,
a beautiful rich quality to it. And it's
somewhat nostalgic quality. Arguably,
the most famous English horn passage is
the one that you're about to hear, uh,
which comes from the slow movement of
divorce shocks, New World Symphony,
which as you might suspect,
was written here in the United
States actually in Spillville,
Iowa in New York City and in Spillville,
Iowa.
So here's a little bit of the English
horn solo out of the new World Symphony.
It's lovely. Lovely. It's funny
about using 40 can do for you.
My mother's family would
actually from Iowa farm family,
from Iowa and as a child they took
me to spill. I would get in the car,
we're going to get culture this afternoon,
pneumo softball games.
We're going for culture.
So we went to Spillville.
I can't hear that music without thinking
of that particular family or those
particular people in Iowa. It's weird.
It's kind of a, as we said before,
music is kind of an entry to the inner
recesses of your memory sometimes,
uh, in any of it. Aside
from that discourteous,
let us continue now with
the brass family. Uh, we,
what were the two instruments in the
orchestra that we have encountered up to
this point in terms of brass instruments?
What have we heard? And in a symphony,
Elizabeth, uh, the trumpet and
the trombone. Okay, fair enough.
Trumpet and trombone.
And there's one other important one that
actually was in the orchestra before
the trombone. Chris, the
French Horn and employee.
In fact that trumpet and French Horn,
we're kind of in their first.
Then Beethoven with the fifth
symphony brings in the trombone,
but it's not until the 19th century
that the trombone gets added to the
orchestra. Where does
Beethoven do so? Well,
he does it in the finale of his fifth
symphony when he wants this particularly a
powerful brass sound.
So let's listen to the um,
uh,
opening of the finale of
the fifth symphony where the
trombones are brought into
the orchestra for the first
time for this particular effect.
[inaudible].
So that's how Beethoven gets
this kind of heroic effect.
He's doing three things here in the
finale. One switching from minor
major,
uh,
he has it's very triadic theme and
he's bringing in the heavy artillery,
the newly invented heavy artillery,
or at least newly introduced
heavy artillery of the there.
And it gives it this powerful,
if you will in the vernacular sort
of ballsy effect with that brass.
And this got extended to
the low brass as well.
The one family and the brasses that
we've talked about that we haven't really
explained in terms of the history
of the orchestra. Is the Tuba here?
When does the Tuba get introduced? Well,
it gets introduced right about this time,
about 1825,
1830 or so.
The first composer to
use the Tuba, um, uh,
in an orchestral piece was Hector barely
o's in this San phony phone testes that
we're going to be embracing
and sections, uh, this week.
So we have the Tuba coming in here and
actually it was, as you can see there,
I'm originally an instrument
called the office lead.
It was a French instrument and barely
owes heard this as a kind of giant key
bugle in the military bands of the period.
Think of the French Revolution.
Think of the Nepal Napoleonic wars,
all of these troops marching up and down
with the brass bands along the showns,
the lycee.
He hears this,
he brings US military instrument into
the symphonic orchestra to add depth to
the lower part of the brass.
Says,
let's go back to our
divorce Jacques piece here.
Divorce Jacques New World Symphony second
movement. And here we can hear the uh,
uh,
the,
the power and the depth of the
newly enlarge brass section
by the two buttons.
So that,
that something of the
Brass Group as an ensemble,
let's think of these
instruments individually.
If we look back at a symphony by Mozart,
not only is the orchestra stronger,
but how he is using these brass
instrument is very different. Uh,
we looked at the French horn before and
we're now going to focus on the French
horn in the very beginning of our course,
we had professional French horn just
in here, eva heater, and she played.
Does anybody remember anything of interest
about the instrument that she played
and how it differed from
the modern French horn?
What didn't that instrument have
that the modern French horn has?
Uh, Roger Keys. Okay.
Keys or valves. Yeah, that's it. Exactly.
Keys or vows that gets
put on the instrument. Uh,
instead of sliding in these crooks
and exchanging the length of pipe.
That way they figured out a way of having
vowels and you could do it quickly and
with keys, but that's a century
invention. 18th Century Horn,
just kind of overblown and it could
play some things such as data.
I'm very easily repeated pitchers that
[inaudible] at the top upon remember our
horn concerto of Mozart
or a bomb bomb bomb.
It could overblow up the harmonic
frequencies up the partials,
as we said before, uh, with ease, but it
couldn't play chromatic kinds of things.
And as a result, it's kind of
stuck there in the background,
kind of providing what I'd like to think
of as a sonic glue for the orchestra.
But it rarely plays any solos in the
orchestral fabric outside of the concerto.
Well,
let's see what happens to the French
horn inside of the orchestra here in the
19th century where it begins to come
forth as a solo instrument because the
melody it can play is so much more
complex and much more interesting.
So here's a famous a French horn
lick out of Brahms first symphony
[inaudible]
back to the horns.
Listen to the depths. Okay,
we're going to stop it there.
So,
so lovely passage,
but it's featuring the brasses and
particularly the Solo French horn.
I guess the thing also did notice here it
is how slow the music is going. Slowly,
the music is really just cut of all slow
down and kind of going at a crawl here.
Um,
and that's an interesting point about
the whole 19th century notion of time and
what they thought about time and
the passage of time, you know, it,
the early 19th century,
beginning of the discovery of the whole
discipline of paleontology and how old
the earth was and how,
how many years a civilization
had existed and so on.
And there's all getting extended and
said Biblically, five to 7,000 years,
now it's 25 million years, which of course
has been greatly extended since then.
But everything here is being allowed
to slow down. And by way of reference,
let's go back to our Mozart here and
think about how he constructed it.
MMM.
Well there we had the,
again,
the beginning of Anna Karenina
music and he has a chordal pattern.
Triadic going up that pattern last
about four seconds. If it bombed,
two, three, four come down. One, two,
three, four, four seconds on each court.
He's moving through his material rather
quickly and we'll say why in a moment.
Now by way of contrast,
let's go to music.
Oh 60 or so later years or so later in
the middle of the of the 19th century and
focus on an overture by Wagner here
overture to the flying Dutchman.
Um,
and we're going to listen to just the end
of this insertive think about how long
Wagner can sit on each chord.
Mozart thought he could sit on each
cord here for about four seconds.
How long does Wagner sit on the court?
Okay.
[inaudible] all one chord change
another cord.
There's triadic notes in that one chord.
Changes that to minor,
just drops the third down.
Same Chord.
And now back to the original
holding that one.
Okay.
Are we on the counter there?
Nine 52 so we had 52 seconds of music
there and we went through three chords.
So we're averaging about 18 seconds
per cord, something like that.
Four or five times more
than Mozart was doing.
How can Wagner do that? How can
Wagner do that? What's the difference?
Why did Mozart have to move
through his courts faster?
What's happening in this music?
Supposing you've tried to play that
Wagner music with Mozart orchestra,
it wouldn't work. It wouldn't work.
Once I had this dinky little orchestra,
how many people were in
Mozart's orchestra? Well,
depends on where he was at a given time.
Haydn's first orchestra had
16 people in it. Mozart,
when he gave a concert in Vienna,
usually wanted about 30 to 33.
We would get to Beethoven.
We're up to 50 to 60 in a typical
Beethoven Ian Orchestra in Vienna,
1810 or so. As we move into
the later part of the century,
these orchestras keep adding more and
more instruments, more and more players.
You've got to balance, well, if
you're gonna have all this brass,
you've got a brown ones than with more
string players. So we're getting up to 80,
90 a hundred by the end
of the 19th century.
So this, uh, this is,
um, an important point.
Mozart had a very small orchestra
and as a result, or maybe,
uh,
he could get away with what he had
because he had great musical ideas right?
He had to have great musical ideas
because the sound itself wasn't going to
rescue him with Wagner
and these later composers,
they may not always have to have
the greatest of musical ideas.
The triad is not a particularly
novel musical idea. Uh,
but he can get away with just taking,
you can get away with doing that and it
sounds great. I mean everybody, it didn't,
we like that Wagner there and then it
sounded terrific and it's just because
he's got this huge orchestra sound
per se is replacing musical idea,
Mozart, terrific ideas,
Wagner, terrific orchestra,
and he knew how to, how to use it. So, uh,
being an orchestra allows longer
movements. I have said before,
I think it is axiomatic and music,
the more people you have on a
stage or involved in performance,
the longer that performance
is going to take.
And with regard to the symphony,
how long does a movement
within a Mozart symphony take?
If you were to look at the cds
appear of a Mozart Symphony,
what would you guess first movement
of Mozart's g minor symphony.
How long does that go?
Yeah,
who said that? I can't. Okay.
Oscar says seven minutes. Yeah.
And actually that's about
right for the g minor symphony.
It's ended up one of the shorter ones
that most people will say five to 10
minutes, 10 minutes outside.
If we get to Beethoven,
how long will a movement of Beethoven
take? Well, about 20 minutes.
Uh, sometimes with his bigger
symphonies, like three, five, and nine,
when we get to, uh, um,
Mahler and Brookner, the, um,
uh, length of the movements
can go on even more.
And an entire symphony of Mahler
might go on for an hour and a half.
So these are bigger.
The big orchestra has led
to longer symphonies. Um,
and the of obviously is very
luxuriant, very opulent, uh,
sound in music,
probably never gets any more opulent
than it does here at the end of the 19th
century to other aspects involved here
having to do with the physical world and
in a way,
technology of course,
the 19th century as the period
of the industrial revolution.
And some of these innovations,
uh,
in terms of metallurgy and a design
got applied to musical instruments.
For example, how many have ever
played the flute in here? Okay.
A number of people, both male
and female. And if you look,
I remember the video we
saw of a baroque flute,
it had actually had very rudimentary
key pad on it and you look at a modern
flute and he's got this kid system
with all these things up there,
all of the different keys and extenders
and that's all an invention of the 19th
century that it completely reconfigured
the flute and how you play it in the
19th century. And we've talked about all
these other instruments that got added.
Uh, so I kind of, technological revolution
was applied to musical instruments too.
But the most interesting thing is,
uh,
when you got all these instruments
together, how much sound they could make.
Let's say you were in the 19th,
you lived in the 19th century and you
wanted to hear the biggest sound that
could be made.
What do you think you would do?
Where would you hear the loudest sale?
Um, Jennifer. An Oregon.
Okay, that's good.
That's pretty good. Um, uh,
though it wouldn't have sounded as loud
then as it does now because now we're
using something else. I'll get to, but
that's a good start. Okay. Anything else?
Doesn't have to be musical. What would
get, what would give the biggest sound?
Sarah.
Okay.
I beg your pardon. Acoustics in music
halls. Yeah, we're going to come to that.
But just in the real world,
you're in the city of London,
what's going to annoy you the
most? Make the biggest sale. Roger.
A big, uh, possibly a bell. Yeah,
but that's back when we've had
those since the Middle Ages.
I was thinking of two
things. Cannons. PLO. Okay.
Huge firepower there. Huge,
loud sound, deafening war.
And one other thing that came in the
19th century steam engines and all the
things that it could produce, trains,
steam, whistles, this kind of thing.
But the third thing
really is this orchestra.
When all of these new instruments are
coming together in such large numbers,
and once you have them all together,
you've got to have a place to put them.
So they started building new
concert halls and concert halls.
A particularly good acoustically,
the model for this,
and I don't know if I put this yes, we
did. Okay. It's up there in the board.
It's in Vienna,
it's called the [inaudible] and it's a
famous hall and it's a remarkable hall.
Maybe the most perfect musical hall
ever built. That was the prototype.
And then other concert hall builders
around the world began to adopt it.
We adopted it here in the United States.
Anybody think of a concert hall in the
United States that is particularly famous
and,
uh,
acoustically beautiful outside of Carnegie
Hall that I'll talk about in a moment.
What other one? There's one other, one,
early concert hall in the United
States Symphony Hall in Boston.
If you're ever in Boston,
anybody from Massachusetts here?
Anybody been to symphony
hall? Okay, go in there.
It's a knockoff of the music for Ryan.
So if you want to see what Vianna looks
like, go to Symphony Hall in Boston. Uh,
there's another one, uh, that,
uh, is very close to us here.
It's pretty close to the,
this design and where is that built?
About the same time.
Our Own
Woolsey Hall, a big hall
seating about 2,500 people. Uh,
if you're ever in Woolsey, notice the
fundamentally rectangular design on it.
Go in and look at the floor.
It has a suspended floor there and it
has a suspended floor for particular
reason.
That floor serves as a resonator and
there are other resonators are around that
we need to go into.
But next time you're in Wellesley,
go in and bounce because
that's in on that floor.
It's designed to have the
sound resonate more. Now,
what's the problem with
Woolsey? Why don't, uh,
string quartets like playing and wolves?
Hmm.
It's too booming. Okay. It's too
resonant. But what was the model?
The model is,
it gets a Roger.
Okay,
well, it was partly built for the Oregon.
Yeah. Shit. What's bills for the Oregon?
But Woolsey Hall can sound absolutely
marvelous for a symphony orchestra,
not booming and not overly resonant.
If what happens,
I'm Robert.
If it's full of people because people
absorb sound. So all of the booming,
there's the long reverberations cycle
gets sucked out of it into our bodies, um,
as sound absorbers and it produces is
absolutely spectacular symphonic sound.
So that was the model and that's enough.
It's a great,
and I was struck the other
day when he went to Nashville,
they've done the knockoff of the music
for Ryan in Nashville in that Schermer
Horn symphony hall down there too.
It's, it's, it's, I mean it's, it's,
it's brazen, but you know, uh,
just take that design from Vienna and
put it right there in the middle of
Nashville. Pretty interesting. Okay.
So that's another thing we have
to kind of keep, keep track of.
Carnegie Hall is a little bit
different in terms of, of it's,
it's designed. Um, all right,
now let's take a look at what I call the
main line here of symphonic composers.
And it's mostly a German tradition,
right? At German symphonic tradition. Uh,
but that became the model for the United
States and that's why they brought
divorce Jacques here. Tchaikovsky came
to the United States and was involved in,
in the opening of Carnegie
Hall in New York City in 1893,
uh,
as you can see running from Mozart down
to Gustaf Moller not all of them were
German.
A woohoo up there is not German.
Roger Schakowsky
was from where? Russia.
Who else is not German?
Uh, Oscar, I became pregnant.
Um,
barely owes, oh yes. I'm sorry. Of course.
Barely. I see. He's of course French. Uh,
and we'll talk about it Hayman section
tonight. Uh, anybody else? Well,
divorce Jacques, he's check. Okay. So,
but they are all in this fundamentally
German educated tradition extending
really from Bach in, but he didn't
write symphonies into Mozart. Haydn,
Beethoven down tomorrow.
So we're going to go to the end of the
line now and talk a little bit about
Gustaf Moller and if you listen to
ever heard a symphony of Mahler,
if you've heard any music of
Mahler, raise your hand. Okay.
I would say about a third of,
of our class has, let's, um, uh,
talk about that just for a moment.
Uh,
I would say if you haven't
been introduced to Mahler, uh,
don't miss this one.
It's really great stuff and I hope to
be able to convince you of that. Uh,
here today. If you're, you're,
you're kind enough to come along with
this here in this trip along the road of
high art music.
Uh,
and we don't want to miss the pinnacle
in a way of high art music for me.
These two m's are very important.
Mozart and Mahler,
they write some really astonishing
music in different kinds of ways.
So Gustaf Moller, who was he? Well,
he was a Jew, born in Moravia,
which is a section of checklists.
The Voc Kia got his musical
education in Vienna,
was a pianist and principally a conductor.
He earned his living conducting and he
went all around the world conducting,
and we'll talk more about that next
time where, where he conducted. Um,
and he composed mostly in the summertime.
He would go out to the Alps and one of
these mountain retreats where you could
have solitude and he would compose.
And in the course of time,
he wrote principally nine symphonies
and something we're going to talk about
next time,
which is the orchestral song,
but we're focusing on just one
that symphony today. Indeed,
his first symphony,
1888 it starts in an unusual way
with a kind of homage to Beethoven,
homage to Beethoven,
because the beginning of this Mahler's
first symphony sounds like the beginning
of Beethoven's Ninth Symphony,
but let's just listen to a bit of it.
Oftentimes with Mahler,
people talk about the cosmic
quality of Ma Maulers music. Well,
what does that mean? What kind of sound
is cosmic? Well, maybe it's kind of open.
Maybe it's kind of hollow. Maybe it
seems to endlessly spacey in that way.
So here's a good example of of Mahler
style particularly is cosmic style.
Yeah,
okay.
We'll just stop it there.
And those trumpets were sort of offstage
trumpets perhaps giving you more sense
of a far out distance.
So that's the beginning
of the first movement.
And I've put this diagram up here because
it's interesting that so much of the
material that he is working with
derives from a particular complex,
a particular cell of material.
Mauler is a developer,
and that's generally speaking what
this German mainline tradition is into.
Not always.
Schakowsky is not a developer.
He has trouble when it comes to
developing themes. But Beethoven,
Mozart of developer, Beethoven is
a developer. Brahms is a developer.
Mauler is a developer. And what
they develop is a, as I say,
a nexus of musical material.
So this here is the initial idea.
Um, and we can go back to our
technique. He all team Paul,
be minute,
we'll go back down to the palm palm,
which we'll loop back to the tonic.
So we could have one more x down here,
but it's the same x is up
there. All right? So that's,
that's the essential motive
of the first movement. Uh,
let's go on to hear just a little
bit of the second movement,
which is a delightful scared.
So here of the first symphony of Mahler,
just the scared.
So,
hmm.
All
right.
Just enough of that.
And now we're going to go into a very
strange movement. The third movement,
the slow movement, and bring symphonies.
We usually have fast, slow, scared.
So fast finale. Well, in the
late 18th, early 19th century,
sometimes they'd switched those. They
put the scare. So number two, and then Z,
sketch of minuet number two,
and then the slow movement number three.
So here we got the slow movement is
number three. Let's listen to a bit of it.
See if you can recognize the melody
that Maulers working with here.
Okay, let's pause it here. I saw a smile
come over Jacob's face out there. Um,
Jacob,
okay.
[inaudible] Shaka or in German? Bruder
Martin, brother Martin. Forever a shock.
Uh, but what happened to, to brother
Martin or for Frere Jacques here,
he got zapped into the minor.
Okay,
so this is a kind of gloomy
forever Shaka. It's a weird, uh,
a movement in,
in a way.
It's taking the familiar and
making it weirdly unfamiliar.
So that's what happens here in
the, uh, uh, slow third movement.
Now we're going to pass on to the, uh, uh,
fourth movement because that's the big
ticket item for today, this morning.
And I think we have time to cover it.
Um,
it's going to start out with this
gigantic kind of opening fireworks of just
pure orchestral sound and introduction.
And then a couple of
themes we'll crop out.
Did he mean bom, Bom, Bom, Bom,
um,
and then a little bit later,
even bom, Bom, Bom, Bom,
Bom, Bom, bom, Bom, bom.
So we have these two themes
here that would be working with,
and we'll pick up some of the
themes a little bit later on.
So let's hear in all get,
get ready for a big explosion here.
The beginning of the finale.
[inaudible] [inaudible],
[inaudible],
[inaudible], [inaudible] [inaudible],
we'll
can phase that out. So that's the first,
the material there. Uh, and you have the,
using the same kind of exiting
process that we began of course with,
we can make use of it here to kind of
track a, remember these particular themes.
Uh, myself, I can't always hear them,
but if I can visualize him, it helps me.
All right, so we're going to now
go on to the second theme area.
He's essentially following our
Sonata Allegro form here. Um,
and we have a long passage.
It goes on for about three minutes,
but it's a quintessential
moment of romantic music.
It's along the same lines of the
checkoff ski that we've heard before.
So let's just start out here and we'll
listen and we'll comment on what's
romantic about the music
that we're hearing.
End of end of transition
here comes to theme.
All right, let's just pause it here for
a second. What's romantic about that?
Go on.
So listen.
Okay. Yeah, it's a lot of Smyrna notes,
whether that, yeah, it kind of inspires
us to romance. I'm not really sure,
but it's not precise. It's not marching
along. It's not discrete frequencies. Now,
what instrument is carrying the melody
here is particularly good at that kind of,
oh,
what's the germ German word in Vienna?
Schlog goober or something like that
for whipped cream kind of sound.
Probably some German native Germany's
in here. Can tell me. Um, uh, Elizabeth,
what instrument is playing that?
The violins,
and this is a,
this is it,
because the violence had this capacity
for Bronto and the slide between pitches,
it gives us this kind of romantic effect.
So it's not,
it's not marching along at any kind
of precise way here. Um, all right.
So that's my principle point of
warm, lush string sale. Let's go on.
Yeah.
Uh,
okay.
So we jumped ahead to the next rather
than pausing. You know, that's my,
that's my, that's my, that's
my, uh, uh, prob, well, I tell
you what, that's okay. Uh,
we're getting close to end of things
any way. Um, none of the, I think,
uh, we really have only about two
minutes left and I do want it to,
everybody was good enough
to show up on time,
so I'm going to let you
leave on time. Uh, let's go,
just to give you a sense of the sound
here. Let's go to the very end of this.
So let's go to, if you would
please, around 1630. Uh,
it's a long moment, about 20 minutes to,
as long we got about two minutes, two,
three minutes to go.
Uh,
and you're going to hear this
extreme or Castro contrast here, uh,
as it gets bigger and bigger.
Notice that we had a minor theme here.
The same theme comes back,
but he takes out all of the chromatic
minor sound and makes it all major and
we're going to get lots of
heroic trumpet's going up
with that addition to our
theme.
Think about this.
This I'd like to think of
as the last gasp of the,
uh,
traditional high art classical orchestra.
It never got any better than this.
It never got any bigger than this for
reasons that will maybe comment on after.
So let's listen and in
one comment at the end,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
and one final thought. Why
did it stop here? Why did,
what happened in the history of art,
music to change everything?
Anybody have any idea?
Uh,
Daniel,
exactly.
That's what happened.
Electronically produced sound
where you could control,
you can control the decibel
level and reproduce it.
People started staying home and playing
recordings and they could manipulate the
volume anyway they wanted at
that particular point. Okay.
Thanks for staying on a have
a great break. We may hope
see it sections tonight,
uh,
and Friday and Monday when you get back.